merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
messieurs les ministres nos communes
rurales s'inquiètent elles expriment
leur profonde préoccupations concernant
les conséquences de la crise économique
et financière sur leurs dépenses et
leurs recettes sur leur capacité à
investir et sur le maintien d'une offre
de service de proximité adapté aux
besoins de la population elles doivent
faire face à une situation sans
précédent l'augmentation de l'énergie
des produits alimentaires et des
matériaux connaissent une hausse
spectaculaire ce qui compromet gravement
l'équilibre des budgets de
fonctionnement et les capacités
d'investissement l'augmentation de 3,5%
du point d'indice des agents
territoriaux non compensés par l'État et
la suppression de la tvae ces mesures de
restriction financière de nos communes
de se justifient pas les collectivités
locales votent leur budget en équilibre
et les soldes qu'elles dégagent
contribuent au contraire à limiter le
déficit public vous les sanctionnez
alors qu'elles ne le mérite pas et 15
milliards d'euros de restriction de
dépenses imposées aux collectivités
locales d'ici 2027 sont en réalité des
restrictions imposées à la population
car c'est autant de moins pour financer
l'offre de service l'Association des
maires de France a fait des propositions
pour indexer la DGF sur l'inflation en
203 pour moduler la suppression de la
CVAE pour créer un bouclier énergétique
d'urgence plafonnant le prix des chats
d'achat de l'électricité pour toutes les
collectivités locales aussi au moment où
se déroule à Paris le Congrès des mers
allez-vous entendre la voix des élus
locaux et soutenir les positions de
l'Association des maires de France je
vous remercie